[Musique]
je suis devenu journaliste pour briser
le silence dans lequel j'ai grandi
pour moi ce silence était une prison une
prison mais aussi une protection comme
c'est la meilleure protection des
espionnes que je suis allé rencontrer
pour ces femmes agent secret se taire
est une question de vie ou de mort
alors entre femmes qui avons appris à
nous taire nous avions forcément des
choses à nous dire
je suis né dans un camp dans le
lot-et-garonne
mon père était un harki un soldat
français d'origine algérienne enrôlé
dans l'armée française pendant la guerre
d'algérie
à la fin de la guerre abandonnés par la
france
la plupart des harkis sont massacrés par
le fln car considérés comme traîtres
mes parents en réchappe et sont
rapatriés en france en 1962 parce qu'ils
les jugent indésirable
le gouvernement français de l'époque les
parcs dans des camps ma famille restera
enfermé pendant 12 ans leur seul crime
avoir servi loyalement le drapeau
français
ce camp c'était une ancienne prison
entouré de barbelés mille familles de
harkis y était enfermée
brimé humilié sous l'autorité d'un chef
de camp fonctionnaires de l'état
français nous étions réduits au silence
par les
c'était risqué les brimades ou les
mesures de rétorsion le rapt des enfants
ou l'internement des pères à l'hôpital
psychiatrique d'agen alentours personne
ne soupçonnait ce qui se passait
derrière ses hauts murs grillagée une
chape de silence entourés nos existences
et nos souffrances comme celle de tous
les harkis arrivée en france le silence
nous reléguer dans l'oubli le néant
l'inhumanité à l'âge de 6 ans j'étais
une enfant très introverti le silence
qui était devenu une seconde nature chez
moi comment cette année tout fait alors
à défaut de pouvoir parler j'ai décidé
d'écrire moi fille d'illettrés
analphabètes
j'ai lancé un défi à la fatalité quand
je serai grande je serai écrivain
c'était un rêve fou je voulais écrire
pour donner une voix à ceux que personne
n'entend pour libérer les paroles
enfouis pour briser ce silence qui ronge
de l'intérieur
à 29 ans devenu journaliste à l'express
je brise une première omerta en écrivant
un livre mon père sera requis pour
sortir ma communauté du monde du silence
du tabou et du secret dans lequel
l'histoire l'a enfermé plusieurs
centaines de harkis et d'enfants de art
qui m'écrivent alors pour me dire à quel
point ce livre a libéré la parole dans
leurs familles et avec leurs proches
j'ai le sentiment d'avoir redonné à mon
père et aux harkis un peu de la dignité
qui leur a été volé leur souffrance
n'était plus nier elle était enfin dit
enfin reconnue elle existait
trait 1 et passe à 42 ans la rédactrice
en chef à madame figaro me propose
d'écrire un article sur les espionnes
d'instinct je sens que ce sujet pour moi
les services secrets qui ont contribué
qui incarna toute puissance de l'état
français ont participé à réduire les
harkis au silence cet article qui devait
me prendre juste quelques jours devient
une enquête donne ans et demi et aboutit
à un nouveau livre cours de mon
investigation
je prends conscience de la résonance
singulière qui existe entre mon histoire
personnelle tenté de silence et de
secret et la vie de ces femmes
invisibles est forte
ces pros du silence m'attire m'intrigue
me fascine saviez vous que dans notre
pays
un agent secret sur quatre est une femme
elle représente une véritable armée
féminine de l'ombre elles sont environ
4000 en france c'est pas mal mais c'est
moins qu'à la cia et au mossad
avant moi personne n'avait encore
interviewé autant d'agents en activité
et encore moins des femmes et pour cause
dans ce monde d'hommes et de pouvoir
elles sont encore plus secrètes que les
agents secrets je sais à quoi vous
pensez
al espionne glamour je rends mathari ou
à la james bond girl ultra sexy je vais
vous décevoir
leur vie est aux antipodes de ces
clichés de l'esp yonne qui obtient des
renseignements sur l'oreiller je n'ai
pas découvert des espionnes française
qui aurait le permis de coucher comme
les espions aurait le permis de tuer non
j'ai rencontré des professionnels
aguerris du renseignement des femmes qui
luttent contre le terrorisme contre les
trafiquants de d'armes les gros bonnets
de la drogue ou la prolifération des
armes de destruction massive croyez moi
la réalité dépasse la fiction
les yeux dans les yeux j'ai longuement
interviewé 50 espionne dans sept
services secrets la dgse
la dgs si le renseignement militaire
financier ou encore le contre espionnage
j'ai vu des femmes de tous âges et de
tous horizons
évidemment elles sont passionnés par
leurs missions de sûreté nationale mais
elles n'en souffrent pas moins au
quotidien du silence qui fait partie
intégrante de leur métier et qui
assurent leur sécurité
je pense à clotilde la quarantaine fine
brume introverti et maman solo
lorsqu'elle a révélé à son ado qu'elle
était espionne il avait l'âge pour tenir
sa langue
il lui a répondu alors pendant toutes
ces années tu m'as menti et maintenant
pourquoi je te ferai confiance
le poids du silence du secret et du
mensonge mine sa vie de famille
il y à aussi camille blonde pétillante
c'est une experte dans la lutte contre
la prolifération des armes chimiques
comme le gaz sarin ou le gaz moutarde
à 32 ans elle part pour une mission de
cinq ans comme clandestino moyen-orient
avec un faux nom info jobs un faux
passeport et infos jobs
mais au bout de quinze jours de mission
elle tombe amoureuse sous cette identité
fictive
pas simple elle finit par se marier
selon la déontologie des services
secrets elles ont le droit de révéler à
leur mari leur véritable profession en
revanche interdiction absolue d'évoquer
les missions sur lesquels elle opère
le soir au dîner lui seul raconte sa
journée
aujourd'hui ce silence
cette impossibilité qu'elle a de
partager son vécu avec l'homme qu'elle
aime fait vaciller son couple
j'ai aussi été très touché par margot 24
ans analyste dans le renseignement
militaire
toute la journée margot visionnent des
vidéos d'atrocités commises par des
chefs notamment des noyades ou des
décapitations sa mission identifier les
bourreaux à l'image ces vidéos ultra
violente sans filtre traumatisante
elle n'a le droit d'en parler à personne
je lui demande comment faites-vous pour
supporter ça elle me répond dans un demi
sourire avec ses dents du bonheur
évidemment à 24 ans on y perd un peu de
son innocence
il y a également charlotte moore
officier traitant la dgse la cia la
française
je lui demande pourquoi avoir choisi
cette vie hors normes dans la
clandestinité
j'apprends qu'elle est petite fille de
mme que ces grands patrons étaient
maquisards pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale et qu'ils se sont battus contre
le nazisme
aujourd'hui charlotte nour et
clandestines dans une capitale arabe et
elle se bat contre le terrorisme
le jour elle et charlotte employés
d'ambassades la nuit
drapé dans un voile blanc elle devient
lourd pour infiltrer des réseaux
terroristes autour de neige
son drame secret c'est de ne pas pouvoir
avoir d'enfant sa vie de masse avis de
danger est définitivement incompatible
avec la maternité
il y as enfin jeanne ex numéro trois de
la dgse
elle se souvient avec émotion d'avoir
entendu en direct l'assassinât d'un de
ses collègues par des islamistes en
somalie
là encore impossible d'évoquer ce
traumatisme avec qui que ce soit elle
m'a aussi raconté le sentiment de
culpabilité
notamment chez les jeunes agents secrets
lorsqu'un attentat survient sur le sol
français le sentiment d'échec et
d'impuissance est alors à son comble est
ce que j'aurai raté un renseignement
crucial qui aurait permis d'éviter le
drame de charlie hebdo ou du 13 novembre
le poids de leurs responsabilités et
parfois vertigineux c'est le blues
secret de l'espion même leur succès
déjoué un attentat libérer un otage
démantelé un réseau terroriste
elles n'ont pas le droit d'en parler les
patrons des services commencent à se
rendre compte que ce poids du secret
défense engendre beaucoup de pression et
de dépression il commence à mettre en
place un suivi psychologique et des
groupes de paroles à l'intérieur des
services
au terme de cette année et demie
denquête je me sens différente
j'ai pris conscience que nous étions
toutes des femmes invisibles est forte
mais ce qui nous fragilise c'est de nous
taire de nier nos blessures intimes de
les enfouir
comme le dit le journaliste jacques
duquesne le silence tue parfois plus
sûrement que les balles parce qu'il nie
l'existence elle même gelé constater
avec les harkis et avec plusieurs
espionne que j'ai côtoyés certaines ne
savent non plus dire je
seul le new subsiste une façon
inconsciente de se retirer
plusieurs m'ont confié que me parler les
avait soulagé libéré car là encore leur
souffrance était enfin dit enfin reconnu
pour moi le silence fait toujours en
bruit d'enfer que l'on s'appelle margaux
ou jeunes que l'on ait 24 ou 50 ans le
besoin de se dire est vitale et ici
c'est possible nous vivons dans un pays
libre et démocratique nous pouvons nous
dresser et parler sans risquer la mort
et la torture
c'est un immense privilège mais trop de
silence résonnent comme des renoncements
trop de silence masquer nos rêves
avortés trop de silence au culte nos
petits arrangements avec nous mêmes
alors je vous encourage à explorer vos
silences allés questionner elle est
déplié allait déployer pour prendre la
vraie mesure de ce qui vous a été imposé
et de ce que vous avez des idées de
terres par les percées ses silences
intime collectif s'est restauré une
partie de soi c'est se respecter s'est
libérée s'est élancé désir c'est
reprendre le pouvoir sur sa vie se taire
peut-être merveilleux seulement si on
l'a choisi
merci
[Applaudissements]